I just feel like people are still in a
lot of pain and trauma and overwhelm
especially if you consume the media in
the news please stop and minimize that
because I think it only creates more
stress when people say this is going to
be the worst week of any week and it's
getting me more deaths like what can
people do in a simple practical step
when they just feel like man there's so
much my head right now what can I do to
start to slow down my heart rate just a
little bit to start thinking more calmly
and make better decisions yeah you know
I think that the moment we switch on
that system for alert or for emergency
we alter ourselves in some way and and
all of that response that we have to an
environment that we perceive as
threatening or dangerous pretty much
causes us to move out of balance and
when you're out of balance you're in
survival when you're in survival you
want to rush to get things done you
can't be present you know you you
believe everything that equal to the
feeling of fear or hostility because
information is is relevant to you in
that emotional state so teaching people
then that they have some type of control
over that that that sympathetic response
that emergency system the switch is on
is preparing you for something you can't
predict yeah that's an unknown something
that you can control and that survival
system causes us to move more into our
animal nature and we're tapping our
body's vital resources and for health
and regeneration so short-term it's
great but you keep doing it over and
over again you start becoming more and
more conditioned to that rush of energy
so teaching people how to self-regulate
teaching them how to move back into the
present moment teaching them that they
can shorten their responses it's really
not that you react and we all react the
question is how long are you going to
react for because if you keep that
reaction going
then you can't perceive any change in
your environment you won't have any
ability to feel so you become more
affected by your environment so simple
process of getting back into the present
moment self-regulating trading that fear
to for some other emotions yeah
and that that's doing the work and but
the practice and that's what we should
be doing because now we have energy to
heal we have energy for repair we have
energy to create now and and work work
we're not losing energy now we're
gaining energy and yeah that's now that
signals the immune system as we talked
about and that's what causes T cells to
make antibodies and antigens
immunoglobulins that fight antigens and
and now your your internal defense
system can can take care of the micro
world where there are invaders where
there are attackers and you have energy
to heal and your immune system as we
said is always combating viruses and
bacteria and and if you're less
responsive to your environment
emotionally then you're less responsive
to your environment physically and you
haven't got more energy and and that
people just need to know the information
because that empowers them to begin to
make different choices and now that you
know you can apply knowledge and make a
different choice demonstrate a different
behavior create a new experience and
that new experience creates a new
emotion Wow
then all of a sudden now you you start
learning new things and you start
stepping away from your old self and
that's what you want people to do
biology changes there's so much
happening in the world there's so much
happening in the country here in Las
Vegas how does one stay positive through
all this well it's certainly not easy
and I know there's a lot of people
suffering and I don't need to make light
of that but you know there's one way
that you don't have to suffer which is
in your head you don't have to do that
and one of the things that I would
challenge the law to do is to remember
she ought to believe everything you
think not all of your thoughts are true
and if you could begin to question what
you're thinking about you're gonna
change your whole mindset and if you
evaluate what is thinking thinking is
the process of asking and answering
questions to yourself so the key to
changing your thinking is to change the
questions you ask yourself and so start
to try to take control of that when they
begin to get away from you and I'm
asking myself every morning and it may
seem hokey but that's changing my
mindset what is this trying to teach me
today what's the lesson this is teaching
me you should get something from your
pain right and if you have to go through
pain at least you should be growing and
changing and evolving and so every day
I'm trying to find the lesson in a visit
that you know maybe in the future you
should save more money so you're more
prepared maybe the lesson is how
important your family and friends are
tea or your freedom or your health but
ask yourself a quality question you'll
get a quality answer and you'll change
your thinking it's fine if you're still
upset discouraged I'm still discouraged
each day I still feel doubt each day I
still feel stress and overwhelm those
feelings spark up but feelings don't
have to own you feelings don't have to
stop you listen my friends feelings are
signals feelings are signals to explore
something to gut check something to act
on something but those signals don't
have to be the thing driving the car you
can say you know what I filled out and
I'm still going to take a step here you
can say you know what I feel discouraged
today so I'm still gonna cheer somebody
on on social media or text you you you
can still move forward even we don't
feel perfect and I think that's one
things right now is so many people they
do they like I don't feel perfect and so
they're just so discouraged I'm not as
confident I used to be I'm not as
motivated as I used to be Brendan
like yeah because you know what there's
a lot going on right now there's more on
your shoulders right now there's just
more on our shoulders right now and
there's more on our shoulders right now
sometimes I can dampen down it if you're
if your Energy's like this it can just
knock it down a little bit because it's
more weight right there's weight of the
world on you there's weight of the
economy there's weight of your family
and the expectations of people around
you and so if you're usually up here and
you feel a little lower right now that's
okay that means it's really important
for you to really focus on your good
habits because if you if you're usually
up here and the weight of the world is
on you now tamping you down and you give
up your positive habits but I am you
know you're in trouble so listen you can
feel the feelings those are signals you
can allow everything right now but the
question is is feeling and allowing
going to prevent positive movement
forward and I'm like no I'm like yes
feel the discouragement and allow it but
then explore why do I feel discouraged
oh that's why I feel discouraged now
what what would I like to do with that
discouragement do I just want to sit
with it here which is okay don't want to
feel it
explore it just observe it let it pass
through do I want to check it do I want
to challenge it do I want to see what
this is about
do I want to explore it logically - all
those are good options so please hear me
I'm not the person saying there's no
good options I'm not saying there's a
right way for you to cope or feel your
feelings your feelings are your own you
never have to explain your feelings
except to yourself and you're the only
ones who know whether or not your
emotions are enabling a detachment from
life or an engagement with life whether
your emotions are cheating you from
feeling the full expression of your
purpose because listen I I'm not here to
say that any emotions are good or bad in
themselves you can feel them and sense
them
but could any person who's ever coached
somebody or any person got any
experience in psychology say you know
there are good habits and there are
habits that lead to not positive things
I think we can all recognize that listen
coping by eating 40 gallons of ice cream
for two months probably not a good
coping mechanism we should be fine and
free to hold ourselves to a standard to
say I recognize this I've gone a little
too far in my coping right let's all be
honest with ourselves
listen I'm optimally a coach and as a
coach I've always got to encourage
people to hold themselves to high
standards and be honest to be honest
about their own behavior either your
behavior supporting you in your coping
right now either your behavior is
supporting you on how you're assisting
people or your behavior right now is not
the mind the mind the human mind can
never be at peace or even create the
experience of happiness so it's very
important to recognize that the mind is
always conflicted because the mind is
fragmented only a whole mind and be
healing and the whole mind is awareness
prior to conditioning now I don't want
to go to too many theories other than to
say it's more important to have a quiet
mind than a positive mind trying to be
positive when you're actually feeling
insecure and unsafe actually creates
more stress so while I give homage to
all those who talk about positive
thinking I think positive thinking
can be also stressful especially if
you're not feeling safe okay so if
you're not feeling safe a positive
attitude can be a little stressful a
positive mind can be a turbulent mind as
well especially if you're trying too
hard to be positive so it is much more
important to have a quiet mind or even a
silent mind you know the silent mind is
the spirit its awareness its
consciousness and consciousness when it
brings silence to our biology it
automatically sets the process of
self-regulation and homeostasis what we
call choiceless awareness choiceless
awareness and so now that we have this
directive this directive from everyone
who's an expert that the best thing that
we can do right now is to practice
social what's the word social
disengagement or social distancing
meaning physical social distancing
because right now we are pretty intimate
socially right here through cyberspace
so we can be intimate and we can be
social without being physically social
for the time being
till this whole pandemic runs out if you
want more advice wisdom guidance from
other successful entrepreneurs on how
you can navigate the coronavirus
situation check out the video right
there next to me
I hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there companies
are now looking into the entire sales
division